when you first got the script what did
you think about the way it was set it's
so intense no it's not you know it's not
you can't write off words like a woman
of it
so suspense failed and you're kind of on
there G asleep so much of it and yeah
really going through this experience
with them yeah you did right there yeah
immersed in it you can't escape because
the screen so big and the IMAX cameras
like here they're very loud
and they're quite big is is that extra
challenge so awkward yes it's amazing
if I wouldn't have it any other way
looks incredible with cameras are huge
we shot entire film on large format film
I mean with its high resolution that's
analog color it's a really real tactile
way of experiencing story this camera
was the main piece because that ever
separate man who was built like her in
the back who would lift it up onto
waiters shoulder sometimes they're right
on the edge of the boat trying to film
in the window and think they're gonna
fall let's draft to the camera as well
so that camera goes down one of them is
gone down as well yeah if you watch the
film like Christmas ever more than like
three or four feet away from you yeah
yeah most physical bit of camera work
I've ever seen yeah when did you first
click into that idea of like this is the
way to tell the story these epic events
they're almost too big to contain and so
what I decided is I wanted to tell the
story intensely subjectively to seeing
these simultaneous stories but they're
also playing out of different time
scales so you're in the cockpit of
Spitfire with Tom Hardy and that hour
you're there with him feels as long as
you know the week that you're dealing
with the guys are there on the beach
then and mortgage it give activated the
civilian boots
digit when you destroy it we're going
Dunkirk we have a job to do